the beauty of getting married is two
people decide to dissolve their autonomy
and create something completely new that
has never existed before and that's this
marriage
and that doesn't mean when you dissolve
your autonomy that means you are living
for somebody else doesn't mean you
dissolve your identity
you're still you you still have your
cool weird things that you're into and
you still have your creativity and the
things that you like you don't dissolve
your personality but you do dissolve
your autonomy I'm living for them now
and they are living for me
and we do this thing together we're
building something new